um
let's let's start with the with the next
talk so it's a real pleasure to have
mark zandry here he's he's going to be
giving uh
he's going to be speaking about his um
his breakthrough result uh
um
with uh
takashi and uh
on uh quantum advantage without
structure he'll also be here tomorrow uh
speaking about uh you know at the
intersection of uh quantum and crypto so
uh
we'll you'll have plenty of time to
interact with them both uh right after
the talking tomorrow mark looking
forward to all right thank you
all right so yes i'll be talking about
my my recent paper here's the title
verifiable quantum advantage without
structure um
so
let's just see what all these terms mean
so this one's pretty simple
um for a quantum advantage we just mean
uh we're looking for a problem that can
be solved in quantum polynomial time but
takes super polynomial time classically
uh this one uh the the other term is
verifiable so we want the advantage to
be verified and what we mean by this
think uh think np we want we want it to
be that the problem if you solve it that
you can efficiently verify that you
solve it
um it's potentially even more
interesting or more broad than np you
can imagine interactive protocols
um protocols with a quantum
verifier but but just think np for
simplicity
um and then the last question and this
is the the squishier one is uh what kind
of structure do we need for quantum
advantage
and this isn't really well a
well-defined notion
and there's certainly many reasonable
ways to talk about structure in this
talk i'll take a a cryptographic view of
structure
and
um and really the heart of the
the heart of it is that with the current
state of complexity theory we there's no
hope of actually proving unconditionally
a a classical lower bound that would
demonstrate quantum advantage and so all
of our lower bounds for classical
algorithms are going to
have to rely on something uh additional
whether that's a an oracle or a
computational assumption
um so we'll i'll be thinking about two
different uh notions of structure so one
is okay so we can't get an unconditional
result uh in the real world so we're
going to do is we're going to pretend
that there's a black box in the sky that
has a function f inside and classical
and quantum algorithms can query this
function
right um
and
what we want here
is for the this function f so so it's
certainly an idealized world where we're
imagining that there's this black box
but we want it to be as close to the
real world as possible and the the most
natural thing to think of here
potentially is that this function f is a
is a uniformly random function now
uniformly random functions certainly
don't exist in the real world but we can
heuristically approximate them with the
you know standard cryptographic tools
the
the other
uh type of structure we'll be thinking
about is a conditional separation so
here there's no oracles are going to be
in the in the standard model real world
um
but we're going to need a comp to make
computational assumptions in order to
justify the classical hardness of our
problem
and
um you know thinking of top typical
assumptions we make in cryptography uh
you know we can you know roughly
okay it's not a line many of these are
incomparable but we can um
we can think about different assumptions
and really what we're going to care
about
uh for structure the what we're going to
define a structure
is that it doesn't imply public key
crypto
and and we'll see why i take that as the
threshold um in a moment
so
what we want is that we can base quantum
advantage on some assumption some
computational assumption who
who's uh if it if it true it doesn't
necessarily imply publicly crypto maybe
it applies symmetric key crypto
um and the the the reason basically for
this is that in order to get public key
crypto all the constructions we have
tend to have a lot of structure to them
again structure being informally defined
um so you know
factoring discrete log pairings they all
have a lot of algebraic structure that
ends up getting exploited by the quantum
algorithm to
to prove easiness um lwe we we believe
is even quantumly hard but it still has
a lot of structure that it lends it to
things like fully homomorphic encryption
um and and this notion of structure sort
of drawing the line between symmetric
and public key crypto also
uh naturally corresponds to our notion
of structure in the oracle setting
because we know that a
uh from random oracles we can get all of
symmetric key cryptography more or less
um
and and yet on the other hand it's
widely believed that from a random
oracle it's insufficient to get uh
public key encryption um and this is the
famous empogliato rooted uh
impossibility results question
this is
this is just a very
this question is just down in the weeds
i'm sorry about that but i'm just i just
wanted to know anyway
on your chart you're taking symmetric
crypto as a synonym for private key yes
and
it's my impression that it doesn't quite
function always mean that it's it's it
can mean that both parties do the same
thing which can that that is possible
for public key you you just mean it
isn't it
yeah yeah so i'm really thinking
when i say symmetric equipment i just
mean private
all right so
um i won't spend too much time on this
slide but uh you know we have a lot of
sources of quantum advantage some of
them are verifiable some of them have no
structure some of them aren't anything
but um
you know at least according to the
definition uh the informal definition of
structure we use in in our paper uh
there's nothing at the intersection here
and that's that's what we're going to
see today
okay so before getting into the results
i just want to say a few more comments
so first if
we want something that doesn't involve
oracles that's just in the in the in the
real world
um all sorts of of advantage for
problems in np that we know of
rely on
period finding the connection the period
finding is often non-trivial but at the
end of the day that's the the quantum
algorithm ends up using period finding
as a subroutine um
and so you know it could be based on
this you might wonder is is quantum
advantage in np is it sort of inherently
tied to period finding or is there
something else
um and this one also maybe this one's uh
less important but
all existing um structuralist sources of
advantage that we have
things like fourier sampling and whatnot
are are all for sampling problems so the
the task is not to find a solution to a
single solution to a problem but it's a
sample from a distribution that closely
approximates some desired distribution
and you can turn sampling problems into
verifiable problems but it's sort of uh
you know with the sampling problem it
could be that there's non-zero support
on the entire domain
and so they're they're sort of seem
inherently disconnected from um
efficient verification
uh and then lastly i wanted to
to just address this incident venus
conjecture
uh which so they stated in 2009 but uh
say that it was uh folklore
for since around 2000 or more or older
and basically i you know forget the
exact details of the conjecture but it
more or less says that if you're looking
at query
complexity that
if you have an algorithm a quantum
algorithm
a that makes queries to a random oracle
and outputs a bit
that there is a classical algorithm that
can simulate the view of a also making
polynomial number of queries
s might be computationally unbounded um
and it would have to be say you know a
is factoring integers but uh in terms of
just the query complexity
s is polynomial bounded and the the
implication here
if this conjecture is true the
implication is that random oracles
shouldn't help separating uh
bqp from bpp
right because for any decision
right the only way in which you could
have a assuming the conjecture is true
the only way in which uh
you know if your quantum algorithm may
couldn't be simulated efficiently is if
s was actually doing something
computationally intractable
but that kind of the whole point of
moving to an oracle setting is to be
able to look at the query complexity
and the conjecture says that looking at
the query complexity won't get you
anything
um okay so
what are our results so we show relative
to a random oracle with probability one
that there is an np search problem
that is in bqp and not in bpp so in
other words it can be solved efficiently
on a quantum computer but not on a
classical probabilistic computer
the reason that this doesn't uh violate
what i just said in the previous slide
about the erinson and venus conjecture
is that
it's a search problem here and if
we go back to the previous slide
um our algorithm here is solving a
decision problem because it's only
outputting a single bit
we actually don't uh say anything about
the errands and convenience conjecture
despite uh you know seeming to
you know get close
um
so yeah there's this mp search problem
in bqp and not in bpp and i guess i
should also say that the decision
version this problem is trivially easy
all instances are yes instances and
that's also why we don't
uh
you know contradict the errors in a
venus conjecture
uh then we we show basically how to
embed the the search problem into
cryptographic objects to get a variety
of cryptographic objects that are
classically hard but
are quantum easy
and then
we also use the problem that's pretty
simple to turn this problem into a
verifiable proof of quantumness so it
allows a quantum computer to prove to a
classical verifier that they are in fact
running a quantum computer
and and
prior results were known but they they
they required lwe structured assumptions
and they also actually were interactive
and lack public verifiability and so we
get minimal rounds public verifiability
to a random oracle
and then lastly uh
we actually say well okay we don't
contradict the a conjecture so we're
going to let's just assume that it still
holds
and then we actually show that we can
lift our verifiable proof of quantumness
into a certifiable randomness protocol
so a quantum device can generate a
random string for a classical client
along with a proof that it actually was
generated randomly
and conditioned on the verifier
accepting this the verifiable will
actually be convinced that the stream
was was uniform
and then you know it's trivially
impossible classically because you could
just have the
the approver run the honest prover
protocol but with no random coins
so we can get this
again this was also
certifiable randomness was also known
from lwe
but it required more interaction we get
less interaction
but now we're also making this uh this a
conjecture
and then lastly this isn't really a
result but we're just saying that
you can heuristically instantiate
the random oracle in our constructions
with some cryptographic hash like shot
256
and
very plausibly get a non-relativized
real world
um
instantiation of all of these objects uh
with conjectured security
and uh you know i guess the point is
that the conjecture the
the
you know the security of of shot 256 is
believed not to imply public encryption
so it's pretty low down on the
spectrum of computational assumptions
all right so let's just dive into the
construction so we're going to start
with some sort of linear code
we will see what properties we need of
it
but we're going it's going to be high
dimensional so here i drew one that's
two dimensions but think you know 100
dimensions or something like that
uh we're also going to want a large
alphabet normally when you're designing
your correcting codes you want to small
alphabet but we're going to take a large
alphabet and we'll see why that's needed
and we also want it to be linear so it
has this you know nice
lattice-like structure
and i'm going to use the word code just
because it it sort of makes sense with
what we're going to end up needing of
this set c but you can also think of it
as like a discrete lattice or something
like that
all right so the first thing we do is
we're going to
just
i don't know if you can really see
uh
what we're going yeah okay this slides
don't turn out so well in here
ah yes so on the screens there you can
see that there's these vertical stripes
um so basically what we what we do
is we're going to first look at the x
coordinates and we're just going to
randomly select half of them and call
them valid and the other half are
invalid
right so now solutions to our problem
are going to be code words that have a
valid x coordinate
how do we choose the what are the valid
x coordinates this is where the random
oracle is going to come in basically for
uh
you know we're going to think of the
random workload the domain is our
alphabet the output is a single bit and
whether that bit is 0 1 tells you
whether the
symbol is valid or not
now this didn't create a hard problem by
any means uh we can randomly sample from
the linear code just by linear algebra
and with probability a half your random
code word will have a valid x coordinate
if you fail you just try again in
expectation you'll generate two random
code words uh before you find a
one with a valid x coordinate
so what we're going to do is we're going
to utilize the fact that we have a high
dimensional code and we're just going to
repeat the process
for the y coordinates z coordinates and
so forth
so for every coordinate what we're going
to do is we're going to choose a random
subset of of symbols and we're going to
say that those are valid for that
coordinate and
what the problem is is to find a code
word where all of the coordinates are
are valid
symbols right and that's it that's
that's the description of our problem
okay well it's not it but that's that's
the gist of our problem and now um we
just need to ask why why should this be
uh classically hard why should it be
constantly easy and in answering these
we'll see what code we actually need to
use
okay so let's start with with classic
hardness
um and i guess just intuitively
we can think of this problem as sort of
an instance of a broader class of
problems that have made appearances in
crypto which i'll call domain
constrained to linear equations the
you basically have so so
what i what i'm calling domain
constrained linear equations is the the
goal is to find a solution to a set of
linear equations that also satisfy some
additional constraints that are
naturally non-linear
so so we can think of the the short
integer solution problem of itai as
a random linear code uh
combined with a low l2 norm
um
random linear code random binary linear
codes with low hamming weight uh so a
different norm here were considered in a
handful of works a few years ago and you
know in general like we we believe cis
is hard we believe um this binary code
with low hamming weight is hard
and so it just it seems likely that if
you have a if your
second constraint is sort of
sufficiently non-linear it seems
like there's a good chance that you
might actually have a hard problem
and in our case we can actually prove
unconditionally that this problem is
classically hard
using using the random oracle so so it's
a query complexity lower bound saying
that you know the number of queries you
need to make to the random oracle has to
be exponential and maybe i won't spend
um too much time on
on exactly why but the
the the gist is
if c satisfies this property of list
recoverability
um
we can actually prove classical hardness
and rough
roughly what list list recoverability is
a generalization of list decoding where
for every
uh so what right what is list decoding
you have you have a sim one symbol for
each every position and you're trying to
find all code words that could
uh
match a sufficient fraction of those
symbols
list recoverability just generalizes
that so that you have a list of symbols
in each coordinate
and if you have a list recoverable code
we can prove this is classically
intractable this isn't
particularly novel on our part um there
was a related construction
their goal was something completely
unrelated um but they also used list
recoverability together with random
oracles to build a
hash function that was hard yeah
so if the code c is list recoverable
then it is classically hard to find a
solution for a problem
in the random relatively
so define a code word where all of the
coordinates are valid yeah already
i'm missing a sentence or just just you
know bicep the right direction right
good so so so right what is list
recoverability is for every every
coordinate you have a list of code words
and um
you want to be able to
find all code words that sort of lie in
the appropriate every symbol lies in the
appropriate list or maybe you can have a
few of the line outside the list
and the idea is that these um so if you
can
if you can find all codes in particular
it means that the set of such codeword
tests can't be too large
and you can um
the the sets of these s's are the sets
of symbols for every position you can
think of them as the queries that the
classical algorithm makes
to the the oracle and so
and so actually this recoverability
trivially gives you a classical hardness
floor bound against um i want to make
all the queries in parallel
so if all the queries are in parallel
literally what you say is i look at all
the queries for every coordinate
and list recoverability guarantees that
there's a sub x
so it's not quite polynomial it's so
exponential guarantees that there's a
sub exponential number of code words
that could be consistent with the
queries that the adversary made
and then for every then it's just a
union bound for every code word that you
have there's a there's a exponentially
small probability that it was valid um
you have sub-exponential number of code
words and now you get your your
exponential order on
so
you just mean code
vectors over the alphabets uh and then
we this is the one proper
we'll simulate another property later
for now this is the one property that we
will require
right so so the connection between it
being a code and it being sort of good
you know classically hard the problem is
that sort of you know you could say if
you make few queries then sort of
because it's a good code then there
should be no code words that are
concerned no no codeword's consistent
with the queries you made and then
anything that's not consistent you're
just guessing randomly exactly okay
yeah so essentially essentially what
list recoverability says informally is
that um the best strategy to attack our
problem is to just sample random code
words and hope for the best
right so the way the oracle shows up is
that um
it is really you know so we're
we're setting the queries to the article
to be these that's s
right so if you didn't have if you
didn't have an oracle you couldn't you
couldn't it's not well-defined to talk
about queries that's kind of the first
part where the oracle comes
up uh yeah so in this theorem down here
list recoverable implies uh you know so
if i were to write it formally if the
code c is listed coverable then
um any
classical algorithm making the sub
exponential number of queries would have
a exponentially small probability of
finding a valid word
why is it called least recoverable it
seems like something is not possible to
do and it seems that something should be
possible to do with aquatic definitions
i mean it wasn't my term
but the the the idea is is you're
yeah i mean i don't know why why it was
called recoverable as opposed to
something else but usually
when you usually it's it's a
generalization of list decoding and
usually we think of lists of coding you
want to be able to
take take your set of symbols and find a
bunch of find the code words consistent
with the symbol so it's usually an
algorithmic problem to to do so
efficiently we're we're turning it on
its head and saying we're going to
actually use the existence of the
efficient vector we actually don't even
care that's efficient we just care that
the size of the set of possible
um consistent codewords is not too large
but yeah you usually it's a it's a
design goal in order to get efficient
algorithms that you want something to be
list decodable or less recoverable
and
we're using it
okay uh so that's classical hardness i
think the more interesting part is
quantum easiness so so why should this
problem be be quantumly easy
and what we're going to do is we're
going to use a technique that was used
by regev
when he defined the learning with errors
problem and um we're going to change it
but uh this is sort of the origin of the
idea
so
uh
something that i call multiplying
quantum states and what do i mean by
that i mean that so i have two input
states uh and
so i'm going to be talking abstractly
for now we'll see the connection to our
problem in a moment
um so so here's here's the general task
i have two input states
uh here i have a dirac comb and a and a
gaussian and what i want to do is
multiply
the states together in the sense that
the the weight so the the domain here
the
the x's range over the same values for
both of these states and i want that my
output state
um just the weights on every x are the
product of the weights in the original
states
and uh you know in general this this
there's a normalization factor here that
that's that is sort of important but i'm
going to largely ignore
um
but this is this is the idea
we want to be able to do this
and um and i guess just a so looking
ahead why do we want to do this well
basically our our problem as well as
these you know general domain
constrained linear equations there are
sort of two easy problems one is solving
the linear system and then one is
finding you know short vectors or
finding vectors with valid x coordinates
that may or may not be code words
um and what we're going to do is we're
going to sort of individually solve the
the two the two problems and then use
uh the state multiplication to try to
combine the solutions together
um okay so how might we how might we
solve this problem how might we compute
the the multiplication of these two
states
uh well we're going to do the one thing
that um i know how to do with signal
processing and that's switched to the
fourier domain
and in the fourier domain
so now our two states become some other
states
and
the product states uh there's this
well-known convolution theorem that says
that the product of the two input states
when you switch to the fourier domain
becomes the convolution of the
um the fourier domain version of your
input
so um we've we've now changed our
problem from computing this product to
computing this convolution
and
why why does that help us
uh well here here's why so here's our
here's our blueprint so we're going to
assume that we can construct these two
input states separately let's just
immediately look at them in the fourier
domain
and so we can write the the joint system
like this
then what we can do is
we can add in superposition so we can
take x and y
from our two input states and we can add
them together to get x plus y and that's
what we need for the convolution now the
the the tricky part is that our quantum
operations have to be reversible so we
can't just replace x comma y with x plus
y that's not a reversible operation
given x y you can't you
information theoretically you can't
figure out what x and y were
um so
what we'll think of doing is
mapping x comma y to x comma y comma x
plus y or you could have you could even
done just x comma x plus y or something
like that but the point is you need uh
in order for this to actually
make sense and be physically realizable
you need to keep at least one of x and y
around
then the last step is to somehow get rid
of this lingering uh x or x comma y or
whatever
um
in order to just be left with x plus y
at the end and then if we can get rid of
x comma y here this is exactly the
convolution this is exactly what we're
trying to solve
right and using the using the
reversibility of quantum computation you
know going from x comma y comma x plus y
to x plus y
it's equivalent to go from x plus y to x
comma y comma x plus y
um so so what we're going to even though
we're going to you know be going in in
the one direction we can think of it as
really we're trying to go from x plus y
and actually figure out what x and y are
from that so it becomes a decoding
problem
um taking x plus y and mapping a text
comma y
right uh okay so we're for now we're
just going to assume that we have we can
construct them separately this is this
is basically trivial and then this is
where kind of all the interesting stuff
happened and it's certainly not even
always possible there's uh you know
right like as we said x plus y in
general does not reveal what x and y are
um uniquely
uh but we're hope we're going to hope
that the nature of our problem actually
allows us to do this decoding
so uh just as an example you can so
reggae's uh
proof was sort of more complicated
because he was proving something
slightly different
um but you can actually view reggae's
proof of the hardness of lwe as an
application of this
um so so what does he do
so the one state is the indicator
function for a linear code
and the other state is going to be this
gaussian weighted um
superposition centered around zero both
of these we can construct without too
much difficulty
um so if we were to if we were to say
you know measure the first state we get
a random code word if we were to measure
the second state we'd get a short vector
uh and then if you compute the product
and measure that
uh the product is going to be short
vectors in the
in the code which is the short integer
solution problem
so reg i've said is okay we want to
solve the shortener solution problem
so let's switch to the fourier domain
um
the
the
fourier transform of the indicator
function for linear code is an indicator
for another linear code called the dual
code
um the fourier transform of a discrete
gaussian
is another gaussian or
there's some error term but you know we
can think of it as some other gaussian
and now what's the convolution it's you
know the superposition of of x plus y's
which is you know basically random dual
code word plus random small error and
this is the lwe problem
so if you could solve the lwe problem
uh you know so taking a noisy code word
in the dual code and actually figuring
out what the code was
then through regards reduction you would
be able to solve cis
uh now regev was unable to solve the lwe
problem and in a sense become you know a
famous uh conjectured heart problem in
cryptography
um and this uh
this proof can be sort of turned on its
head to get give justification for the
hardness of lwe because you can say well
if i'm confident that cis is hard then
lw must be hard as well because if lwe
were easy then then you could complete
the reduction you can complete the
reduction in solstice
right so that that was uh
that was regiv's work
and now what we're going to do is try to
apply this general idea to to our
construction to our problem
so we're going to do the same thing for
these alpha x so our first state is
going to be the indicator function for
a ran for this code c
which again we can just construct easily
using linear algebra
and then um the other state are going to
be the indicator
uh is going to be the indicator function
for valcoin so it's basically going to
be a superposition over all vectors not
necessarily in the code but all vectors
that have valid coordinates
and then the product state is just the
intersection of these two which is
exactly what we want it's going to the
product state's going to be a
superposition over solutions to our
um problem they're going to
superposition over
um code words that have all valid
coordinates
so so what we need to do then okay so so
we're going to try to solve the
multiplication problem for these two
states
so we need to figure out if we can solve
the
uh
the convolution problem which then
reduces to solving this decoding problem
so what is what is the decoding problem
um so here's
our
our okay so
the dual codes of is just going to be
the you know some some other linear code
um and then the what's what the more
interesting part is going to be the
valid coordinates
so if i were to zoom in just say on the
x-coordinates
right the indicator function is just uh
it's just a random function right it
says for every
symbol with probability half it's one
with probability half
um it's zero um so up to normalization
anyway
uh this is what our state looks like for
for a single coordinate it's just kind
of randomly oscillating back and forth
between zero and one
and then our our overall state for the
valid coordinates is just the product of
these kinds of states for every for
every possible coordinates
so when we when we when we look at
something like this in the fourier
domain it actually
has a pretty nice form
so the
um we're going to have the the fourier
coefficient at zero is going to have
this big spike and where the magnitude
is about a half and that corresponds to
the fact that this uh you know the the
area under
the um the primal signal uh is about a
half right because an expectation every
point has its value is a half
um so we have this huge fourier spike at
zero and then all of the other fourier
coefficients are are
are basically uniform there there's a
there's a complex phase that encodes all
the information it needed to sort of
reconstruct the
the oscillation back and forth and the
primal domain but if you just look at
the magnitude you get essentially
uniform
so what is x plus y
then and once we move to the fourier
domain what is x plus y well x
is going to be a dual code word
and y
is going to be a vector
of things distributed like this
right so basically in every position
we're going to have a half chance that
the vector in that position will be zero
and a half chance that it'll be uniform
in the rest of the domain yes you just
said one dimension here or
uh so so so this
because i can't draw in multiple
dimensions this is just one
coordinate and then you're gonna have
you're gonna have the product of of many
of these for every single coordinate the
k exponentially then the norm
of on zero
this is this is it's a finite domain
right it's just whatever our symbol
space for the code is okay um
yeah so i mean maybe the way i drew it
sort of uh
makes it look like it should decay
otherwise the the area under is
exponential or infinite but no it's so
it's a finite domain
um just whatever the size of our symbol
space is and but the the the crucial
point is just that it has this spike at
zero and is essentially uniform
everywhere else
and then we repeat that for every single
coordinate
um right so so x is a dual code word and
y if every single coordinate basically
has a probability of a half of being
zero and a probability half of being
random and so what we get is that our x
plus y is dual code word plus
random errors in about half of the
coordinates so in other words about a
quarter of the bits are flipped
uh
well these i mean
right there and in general our symbol
spaces will actually be exponential
um
right so so this this is actually a well
known problem in coding theory right you
have a you have
a code word you introduce some errors
and you want to you want to figure out
what the original code word is that's
the decoding problem
and
this is actually often one of the
examples of where list decoding is
motivated
because we're we're basically it turns
out going to want to
correct for more errors than you can
handle with unique decoding
but
we can use list decoding and then just
use the fact that where we when we have
errors they're uniformly random to argue
that actually the there is only a unique
uh code word
um even so in the worst case there could
be there could be a lot of code words
but
um on um with overwhelming probability
there will always be a unique code word
for the
um
sort of the parameters we choose can you
say a lot would it still be only
polynomially many yes excellent
yeah so it you know it sort of depends
on the exact parameters so what we're
going to want is we're going to choose
some it could be a constant let's say
epsilon that's pretty small
and we want to we want to be able to
decode a half plus epsilon errors
um right and that basically right
because so we have errors in around half
of the position but it could be a little
more than a half but with overwhelming
probability the number of errors won't
exceed a half because that's one
um and then we want to be able to list
decode that and for any constant epsilon
you
you get
certainly a polynomial upper bound
yeah i
so we're gonna need
um
epsilon will also come in for classical
hardness as well
um so i don't know how high we can set
up on i think we give example in the
paper
and you can get maybe up to three
quarters or something
mark
can you say something again about the
issue of of the normalization so i have
a slide on that oh okay okay
um
uh this crucial stage in the algorithm
then is
sort of
you could call pseudoclassical i mean
classically yes
to to to a quantum circuit yes the only
quantum part of our algorithm is the
ability to run classical algorithms
different position and the fourier
transform to go from the
the primal domain to the fourier domain
in order for us to be talking about the
convolution
yeah but other than the the other than
those two aspects of it it's it's
possible it's just this decoding
um i suppose in principle you could have
a quantum decoding
really really we're just using the
classical stuff and superposition
um and okay so
i already spoiled it but um
so we need the dual code to be list
decodable
and remember from before that we needed
the primal code to be this other thing
called list recoverable
and it turns out that
the
um
only
codes that are maybe not the only codes
but um sort of the first class of list
recoverable codes that was proven to be
list recoverable were these things
called folded resolment just think of
them as as reed solomon but uh there's a
little bit of a nuance there
um
and so those were proved to be list
recoverable and just so happens that the
dual of reed solomon is essentially
another reed solomon code which we also
know is less decodable
so
so we that that's going to be our code
then is
these folded retelling codes and that
that allows us to prove classical
hardness and also get
recoverability or list decoding in order
to get their quantum algorithm
um okay yeah so that's that's the that's
sort of the main result and now i i did
want to mention about the
the the error terms um and then i'll
i'll talk about applications in the
last um so if
we are
looking at the
the actual convolution theorem what does
the actual convolution theorem say say
um it says that if you take the fourier
transform
of
um
the the product state you get you know
the convolution state but we pick up the
square root of n factor here
and n here is is the is the size of the
entire domain which is huge um right
first it turns out we need our symbol
space to be
um
super polynomial and then also we have a
high number of dimensions so it's you
know super polynomial raised to the
rate of something so certainly this n is
huge
and so you actually
um what happens is if you try to naively
analyze the error terms
uh just kind of the straightforward
thing you say like okay some of these x
plus y's will decode some won't
and and some won't decode because you
know in the worst case we in the worst
case you can't decode past a half
fraction of errors
um so certainly certainly there will be
some chance of errors it's you know it's
negligible but then you get blown up by
the square root of n factor and suddenly
things aren't looking so good
um so it turns out for regev this wasn't
an issue for regev um just the sort of
the you know the particular
uh the particulars of the gaussian
having these really really small tails
um
meant that the error term was at was
actually much smaller than um one over n
so
you know
he could actually do the most obvious
thing um and to abound the error terms
and actually get them to be small
in our case though the error the errors
while while negligible they're basically
like two um they're
like
one over two to the minus dimension
um which is much bigger than um one over
n inverse where remember like this n
inverse depends also on the size of the
alphabet which is huge
um so we we get this uh
we the naive approach gets this uh the
error probability ends up being you know
100
so it's uh we have to do something else
uh and i won't really say much about it
we we
we have to do a delicate um analysis
that basically uses the symmetry of the
problem so so it sort of inherently
relies on the fact that the oracle is
random
and also that the
um the decoding algorithms are sort of
some the decoding probability doesn't
depend on your original code word
uh
right so no matter what code word you
started from you add error your decoding
probability is the same
it only depends on the error term and by
by sort of combining these two and doing
a more delicate analysis we were
actually able to get the uh
yeah and so so i guess at the end of the
day
in order for if you were to
heuristically instantiate our algorithm
with shaw
you're actually here sticking the
correctness as well
if it stopped working there then you
would have distinguished uh from ransom
right which i mean the shaw's clearly
not random because it has small code but
it would be it would be a
surprise um
you know cryptographers have been
assuming that the hash functions uh
behave randomly for for a long time and
it's part of accepting contrived
examples
so would be surprised
yeah um i will say so we have an update
for the paper that's not public yet
where we can
um we still have to end up using the
delicate analysis but we can make
correctness hold through any workforce
um we change we have to change the
problem slightly um
yeah i don't want to spend i don't
really want to spend time on it
right so yeah the idea is that uh i
guess the the gist of the idea is that
with a um we can
so we really we don't necessarily need a
uniformly random oracle we can get away
with koi's independence for sufficiently
large k
um that's just a
product of the fact that our quantum
algorithm is efficient
um
and so what we what we do is actually we
change the problem so that you supply a
ky's independent function together with
your solution and then your solutions
defined relative to the uh the xor
of the oracle and your your supplied kos
independent function and that makes your
function now the whole the the export
function makes it um ko is independent
so you can get the classical algorithm
to work um then there's an issue with
quantum classical
hardness that breaks classical hardness
so we have to do some parallel
repetition
but in any case you know the
we we're still going to need to
basically use this delicate analysis um
yeah i don't i can't i don't think i can
really say more than just
you have to you have the point is you
have to be careful with these with high
probabilities
um
and you can't just uh assume that it
works you have to actually
look
okay so so now now i want to talk about
the applications so so the first is uh
this one's rather simple so how do we
take this problem and actually get an mp
problem
that's in
bqp but not bpp
so
what we're going to do
is
we are going to define
this np relation
that so the instances are just uh
bit strings of length n and witnesses
are
vectors of symbols of length n
and what
what is uh
so when is one is a instance witness
pair valid
it's when the witness is in the code
and the
uh the symbols all hash to the the x
bits in the instance
um technically this changed the problem
right because we were saying the problem
was
um you know all of the symbols hash to
say one uh but everything's symmetric
because we have a random oracle here
so
so it's you know you can replace zero
with one and you still get a hard
problem so this becomes our rnp problem
here
um
right
and no not one thing about this np
problem is that the decision problem is
easy right so
basically
with with overwhelming probability uh
over the choice of oracle
it will be the case that all x's are in
the language there will always exist
these code words just by the you know
because the the code isn't too sparse
and the
set of code words is so large relative
to two to the end
the size of our the number of our
instances
that with overwhelming probability all
instances will actually be
uh in the language it's just that it's
hard to find it's classically hard to
find a witness
right so that's why i say oh keep saying
np search problem not decision
um we can get classical and quantum
separations for crypto primitives so
here's you we can easily turn this into
a one-way function
that is classically hard to invert but
quantumly easy what's the one-way
function well the domain is codewords
and what you do you just hash each code
word separately oh and i should mention
that i i'm prepending these uh sort of
the the coordinate
name to all of the code words and that's
just for domain separation to make sure
that all of the all the coordinates sort
of get their own random oracle
right so this is a one-way function why
is it one way well
inverting this one-way function is
exactly solving the
search problem on the previous slide
uh right
and now proof of quantumness uh so what
is a proof of quantumness
um it's something where you have a
a a classical verifier here interacting
with a quantum proverb and the the
provers trying to prove that they're
quantum so
the completeness of the protocol says
that the quantum prover actually can
convince the verifier called the
verified output one
um but if our prover were classical then
we want that the verifier you know
always rejects always output zero
um
and so what we can get is
uh we get a simple proof of quantumness
what's the proof you just you just solve
this problem you just solve our
our hard problem and the fact that you
solved it means you
you know by the assumed class or by the
proven classical hardness relative to an
oracle the fact that you solve it meant
you must be
there's a little bit of uh subtlety here
in that
the the model in which we can
um prove
that our proof of quantumness is secure
really requires um a uniform uniform
adversaries that are independent of the
oracle
and this is not necessarily the
the best reflection of how things are
modeled in the real world so if you were
if you were
to
um have a
in the real world if you're going to
consider a non-uniform adversary that
non-uniform atmosphere could always have
a valid proof of quantumness
uh just hard-coded in their description
and and then just output that
so what in the in the sort of real world
if you want security against non-uniform
attackers you you can't have a
non-interactive proof of quantumness
you need some amount of interaction
um and when you're in the oracle setting
the way the correct way to model this is
to basically allow your non-uniform
adversaries to get advice about the
oracle
so um
what we what we show though is that
there's a really trivial solution to
upgrade our
our
you know simple proof of quantumness
into one that also works against
non-uniform attackers and that's for the
verifier to just send over a random seed
as the first message and then the the
solutions are defined relative to that
random seed so you hash
uh the random seed together with
whatever you would have hatched with
and um
and we we prove it's it's actually easy
we just take some some prior work as a
black box more or less
um and
uh we we can show that this allows you
to lift
the security against uniform adversaries
to the security
okay and then certifiable randomness
that's the last one i want to talk about
so what is certifiable randomness um
it's kind of looks the same as a proof
of quantumness
except that we actually want um our
verifier here to output a random string
and we want the that if the
um
if the verifier accepts
we want that the string is actually
uniformly random
so you know
and what that implies in particular is
that if
the prover is you know
not using any randomness whatsoever that
the the verifier will
reject
um
right
and so there our observation is kind of
i don't know i i like this so the
observation is that if we take our proof
of quantumness and let's just you know
be in the uniform case where it's just
totally non-interactive
um
uh so
what we can actually say is that if you
assume the a conjecture
that the
uh solution that the ad that the
approver gives us has to have men
entropy
so in our particular protocol for
solving our hard problem and getting a
proof of quantumness
uh the way it works is that the
adversary or the the prover constructs a
uniform superposition over all solutions
and then measures it
to get a single solution
which will be random
and
we can essentially say that some
randomness is inherent if you assume the
a conjecture so there's no way for
approver even if they're quantum
to
actually come up with a deterministic
value for the for the solution
and roughly roughly the way the way this
works the way we use the a conjecture is
okay so suppose that a malicious prover
had some way of generating a code word
with valid coordinates such or you know
a proof of quantumness
such that it was actually deterministic
you know with good probability it'll
they always output at the same value
well you can look at every single bit of
the input sorry every single bit of the
output
and every single bit of the output is
is
just a an algorithm potentially quantum
that
decides something i don't know what it's
deciding it's not a natural language or
anything but it's a quantum algorithm
that decides something it either outputs
zero or one
by the a conjecture there would be a
classical algorithm that does the same
thing that outputs 0 or 1
the same 0 or 1 as the quantum algorithm
but that would then violate our
classical hardness because we can we
could piece these
very for every single bit we could piece
the implied classical algorithms
together to get a classical algorithm
that also solved the proof of confidence
so essentially what the a conjecture
says is that if you have a separation
between classical and quantum relative
to a random oracle
that your quantum algorithm is sort of
inherently randomized
that's kind of the takeaway here
um so what we can get is that
the
uh so this this code word that the
adversary or that the prover sends has
to be randomized
with some entropy and so we we can just
extract from it
um so bob has a little random seed and
he just extracts some uniform random
values from
um from c
right and um again when you move to the
non-uniform setting you can't do this
non-interactively
um
and so you know our solution is to send
over assault again
here uh
the the prior work doesn't doesn't work
generically
um
uh due to the the nature of due to the
nature of these proofs of quantumness it
turns out we can't apply it but
uh
we use sort of standard techniques
so i was wondering if you have
an algorithm which uses
some pseudo randomness like a small
amount of randomness
put that also pass the test
right so the
yeah i mean to be honest i i don't know
if there's like really compelling
applications that proves upon this but
um
right that what you what we want is an
actual statistical randomness to come
out the other end you want that the
output of bob is actually statistically
random not pseudo-random um and this is
this so so you could
if you're pseudo-random that would just
it's not statistically random anymore
sort of violence definition it's it
should be as good as uniformation in any
real application
um
but
technically wouldn't have
philanthropy
but
answer your question i was just trying
to understand the reduction because it
was going through the air conjecture and
i thought that over there you were using
the fact that it's a deterministic
algorithm crucially to
say that
right so so again it's it's you know so
a conjecture says that for the term for
um
decision algorithms that any any
efficient quantum decision algorithm has
a possible simulator and so we just
we we take our
our supposed algorithm that may have
uh you know output of the deterministic
codeword and just look at it look at the
algorithm that output of the first bit
look at the algorithm that uploads the
second bit and that's a decision
pro decision algorithm for something
we we get a bunch of classical
algorithms through the conjecture and
then stitch those together to solve our
problem
um
so if the a conjecture seems to say that
there's a deterministic argument today
um i'm not actually sure if the precise
statement implies there's a
deterministic one or a recognized one
but it doesn't really matter because our
our lower bound works for randomizing
so uh
at least
so
i'm sort of guessing this is so but
although you said large alphabet
it looks like you only need fields of
characteristic two so that the 4a stage
is actually
kind of hard walsh and not so bad
although
although
um i mean so so the characteristic ends
up being larger than two
um
so the so the way these folded
so these folder resolvements code aren't
actually strictly linear um
but essentially what the alphabet is
it's like the queue to the
you know the the alphabets are
um
it's it's of
yeah zq to the end
zq to the m or something
um
that's a good question
um
so i think and i think technic so i
think if your goal is just to get this
decoding unless you're covered early i
think yes
um the the problem is that i'm not a
hundred percent sure with the fourier
transform that it behaves nicely if
you're using a
um
i'm just not 100 sure of the top of my
head okay
it would be helpful i mean like to
compare what you were doing
what you're talking about to scott's
talk it would be a little bit step
this i think that it's the
city coding yeah yeah so so the the the
characteristic uh it's another number
wasn't sure if i could be two but it's
not big um even though the even though
the symbol science ends up being large
the characteristic
it's not huge
but uh yeah i don't think the the
fourier transform is the bottleneck
regardless the um it's probably the
decoding on the one in the superposition
because it just it doesn't seem like it
seems very
insensitive to noise and
very sensitive to noise
rather complex
well you said good question so we'll see
okay okay so so the talk's basically
over um this is kind of the
this is the last slide just um you know
there's a natural question here of
whether this is
whether this is practical gives us any
any hope of improving the near-term
prospects of demonstrating quantum
advantage on actual hardware and i think
unfortunately the answer is no
um do do exactly to this decoding
problem um just
i don't even know if
like even in the even in the classical
literature there isn't there aren't uh i
i wasn't able to find in a short search
uh sort of good classical estimates of
the
like even the exponent in the running
time of the algorithm wasn't spelled out
in the original paper
and then
and then actually sort of implementing
this on a quantum device coherently
i i think it's it's certainly worse than
the the experiments currently being run
and how it compares to shore's algorithm
i i don't know maybe it's
a little better maybe it's a little
worse it's hard to say
but yeah probably probably not any
progress towards near-term
and that's that's that's a thing
[Applause]
wonderful thanks a lot that was a
fantastic talk uh any questions and
could your work say something might say
something about
the
hardness of doing a classical
uh reduction for lattices
like the one or i give content reduction
uh i don't think so um
you know like the
i mean the fact is that for for our
problem to be classically easy we had to
use a particular code and we also had to
use and it's not really a norm but we
had to use like this different structure
of the
of the errors um i guess i guess it maps
to hamming norm or something
um and i think the so in the in a lot of
setting you use random codes
uh and random random codes we wouldn't
be able to decode if we try to use them
and then i also just think that you know
that using l2 norm versus our norm
results in a very different problem with
very different
very different hardness characteristics
so
so you're still your np your search
problem has many different solutions for
each problem statement and i guess under
the a conjecture
you wouldn't expect to have a problem
with a unique solution correct
yes so so if the a conjecture is true it
would say that for any np problem
actually it doesn't even need to be np
really um for any problem with unique
solution any search problem with unique
solutions or even a polynomial number of
solutions um that there there wouldn't
be a separation between classical and
quantum particles can you say a little
about what would go wrong by just like
trying to make the random work output a
little bigger to like narrow down the
number of solutions to unique or
polynomials uh yeah so i mean our our
quantum algorithm will fail and the the
reason is that
um
so
it's it's really the fourier domain
view of our val symbols right so
um i won't go back to it but um so what
happens when you
expand the
um you know the set of possible outputs
of the oracle
is that that spike at the fourier
coefficient of zero is basically one
over the number of outputs of the random
oracle
so if you
you can you know potentially tolerate
uh like log number of bits but once you
go beyond the log number of bits you're
just gonna your errors are just gonna be
everywhere and you won't be able to
solve it
and even out of log bits there will
still be
uh
you know many solutions for every
instance
sorry i guess the other way you could do
it is just
tighten your code but that would also
lead to problems exactly yeah
in view of running this practically um
you said the the bottleneck is the fact
that you have to run the decoding
algorithm in quantum superposition and
this is going to be a huge circuit um
you also have to do the random oracle in
quantum superposition right the sha 256
yes and is that not a bottom line is it
like so
i don't know um this is a short answer
so so so there you know people have
actually tried to
um you know do resource estimates for
implementing sha and i forget what i
don't remember off the top of my head
what the numbers are maybe i put it in
here somewhere
um
yeah you would need hundreds of
thousands of quantum gates i think based
on the best estimates
um now it could be that
right the only reason we okay we need
sha for the
for the analysis of our quantum
algorithm but i'm going to forget that
the really the important
um place where the random oracle
heuristic comes in is justifying
classical hardness and you could just
make a leap of faith and you could even
imagine some like really simple
non-cryptographic hash function
and just make a leap of faith that the
problem remains hard even even with such
a hash function and you could but so you
could potentially
uh get the
the that aspect of the algorithm much
better
you're making a bigger leap of faith in
terms of the classical hardness but
even if you do that you'll still be left
with the
decoding algorithm being
130
[Music]